welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to
chucky once again gets lucky with a big
reboot of the franchise starring aubry
plaza and mark hamill
the doll now has some killer new
features and throughout this video i'll
be breaking down everything that you
need to know about the movie and its
ending
this is full spoilers ahead so if you
haven't seen the film yet
and don't want anything ruined then i
highly suggest that you turn off now
with that out the way i just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
video
i hope you enjoy it now sit back relax
and let's get into my breakdown of the
child's play remake
child's play similar to all of the other
movies in the franchise follows an evil
doll named chucky
that decides to go on a killing spree
however unlike the other films in the
series
there's no voodoo possession and instead
the character is now from a high tech
toy range named buddy
buddy created by the castling
corporation comes with a whole new host
of skills that basically makes it one of
the most
if not the most sought after toy in the
world
it's able to interact with other caslin
products and whilst the majority of them
aren't going around trying to kill their
owners chucky has been given
let's say some special privileges that
allow him to act on his own
this is because a disgruntled worker who
was employed at the business where they
make the doll
decides to one day mess around with the
settings of one of the buddies
after he feels mistreated and
undervalued the worker removes all of
the language and action inhibitors and
this means that the doll can now do what
it wants
basically everything good about buddy
and the worker
goes out the window now since this new
direction was announced
has been a lot of outcry from fans
however i actually think this new
modern take on the character works a lot
better in today's world everyone with an
alexa can relate to this and it'll
probably keep me up at night as i'm
reminded of all the times i've told her
to
shut up basically if you've seen small
soldiers you get the gist of it
the toys are back in town and i don't
mean woody and buzz and this guy is on a
quest to be andy's best friend
unlike the original film chucky isn't
actually out to kill andy
and in the movie he just wants to be his
friend and is even willing to murder
those around him
and he doesn't like we're gonna have to
change the phrase from curiosity to
chucky kill the cat
because this doll doesn't stop when it
comes to trying to be andy's best friend
and yet there's just some awesome
awesome kills in the film
now early on because of this i was
pretty hooked on the movie i was
expecting it to be a big disaster but
they slowly build up the tension making
chucky get more and more sinister
as the plot of the film goes on chucky
to me in this version
is sort of a representation of the world
around him and as he witnesses more
violent
things he ultimately becomes more
violent too it's definitely a smart take
on the doll as it shows that this is
what our kids could turn into
if we don't put rules in place or make
sure that they have a quote unquote
filter
and yet stop playing fortnite all the
time
your eyes will go square anyway
the way that chucky also operates the
other castle and products during his
killing spree showcases perhaps that we
probably have become too reliant on
technology and that it will ultimately
become our downfall
though yeah i'm not sure whether i'm
going too deep on that but
you know it's got a nice sort of thing
against stocking out your house with
nothing but amazon products
it has to be said though that mark
hamill absolutely smashes it
and as we head into the final act whilst
it was pretty predictable
hamill's dynamism kept the entire thing
fresh and unnerving throughout the whole
movie
there's a scene where he presents
someone's face to the characters that is
very
very bloody and it just kind of shows
that this doll is not to be played with
he goes on a huge murder spree and at
some points andy is believed to be the
killer
though this is quickly unearthed by
detective mike norris after he discovers
that the doll can do what it does
after mike is almost fatally injured by
chucky the rogue toy takes andy and
karen hostage
and tries to kill lala by hanging her
from a forklift and he manages to save
his mother and with the help of mike
they decapitate the doll
seemingly killing it now there were
rumors that chucky would survive this
film
however it's pretty clear that at least
this version of the doll gets completely
smashed up by the film's end
and yeah there's no chance of him coming
back however we do see many defective
dolls in the third act
that showcase that perhaps chucky isn't
as dead as the doll is
whilst castling industries issues a
recall we can see that there are
definitely malfunctioning dolls
and if a sequel was to happen then i
think it would be one of these that
would act as a new host for the rogue ai
to return to get revenge on andy
after his bitter rejection the fact that
chucky can also operate other caslin
products
means that he could have a worldwide
reach and if the sequel ups the budget
then the doll could hold the world
hostage due to our reliance on
technology
either that or skynet will develop their
own dolls
and yet we all know how that turns out
so
what did i think of the film overall
well as you can probably guess from my
tone i really enjoyed it
child's play has always been pretty hit
and miss for me but i think it's safe to
say after one watch that i actually
prefer this over the original film
it works far better in a modern setting
and i feel all of the updates that
everyone complained about are actually
necessary
in order to breathe some new life into
the franchise june's been a pretty bad
month for movies so far with only toy
story being a standout
but this is a pretty close second it's
not gonna blow anyone away but it's an
enjoyable watch from beginning to end
and it feels like the studio are taking
good care of the property
overall i had a lot of fun with child's
play i'm interested to see what happens
down the line
and i'm giving it an 8 out of 10. i am
interested to see if my rating changes
after re-watches
and i know what to expect but coming
right out of the cinema
this is a fun ride obviously i'd love to
hear your take on the movie and
if you enjoyed this video then please
give it a thumbs up and make sure that
you check out my breakdown of all the
behind the scenes drama involved with
the remake which will be linked at the
end
i've also done a breakdown of this
week's other big release toy story
so if you want to see some toy figures
fighting it out that's a bit more family
friendly
make sure you click that video after
this this is the channel for people who
are mad into movies
so if that's the kind of thing you like
hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this i've been definition
you've been the best and i'll see you
next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you